tu es la chroniqueuse vraiment modèle je
te le dis merci Géraldine tu resteras
avec moi pendant de très nombreuses
années si tu le veux bien si tu le veux
bien bien sûr jusqu'à ce que la mort
nous sépare merci l en tout cas d'avoir
été avec nous blocage partout en France
opération escargot manifestation
revendication personne n' pu passer à
côté de la colère des agriculteurs
depuis plus d'une semaine malgré les
annonces du Premier ministre vendredi
cette colère n'est pas redescendu les
agriculteurs ont même appelé à bloquer
la capitale et ringist afin d'affamer
Paris euh donc ça va être compliqué pour
toi samedi soir au tout mieux vous le
savez TPMP donne bien sûr la parole à
tout le monde et s entendre les cris du
cœur des Français c'est pourquoi ce soir
nous donnons la parole à des
agriculteurs qui vont être entendus ils
sont avec nous il y a réis et Christophe
qui sont avec nous ils viennent du du
village d'Off fois dans l'Oise ce sont
les c'est un des initiateurs c'est les
initiateurs du barrage dans l'ISE g verd
puis on avoir toutes les images des
images folles voilà de de ce weekend
c'est parti petit recap merci
L
[Musique]
bien merci merci d'être avec nous merci
Régis merci Christophe vous venez deux
fois dans l'Oise depuis combien de temps
vous êtes sur le barrage depuis mardi
matin mardi matin la 16 sur la 16
exactement vous allez nous dire quelle
était votre réaction on va on va revenir
un petit peu sur tout ce qui s'est passé
on va voir sur des images aussi
incroyables il n'y avait pas que les
camions des agriculteurs sur les routes
ce matin mais aussi leurs vaches comme
iris accompagné de son éleveur qui était
au niveau d'ex en Provence ce matin
regardez et oui P il y a une une vache
ici sur l'autoroute 151 elle s'appelle
iris vous voyez est avec Roland qui est
éleveur juste à côté de d'ici on n'est
pas loin d'ex en Provence bonjour Roland
expliquez-nous vous nous disiez iris
elle est en grève aujourd'hui oui parce
que elle en a marre comme beaucoup de
paysans aujourd'hui qu'on a un un tas de
de paporasserie administratif comme je
vous citer le cas moi pour pouvoir
déplacer mes animaux je suis obligé de
passer le captave capacité à transporter
des animaux vivants mais il y a des lois
que on doit on doit pas transporter des
animaux vivants qui sont fin de
gestation alors vendredi Gabriel Atal
Premier ministre a tenté d'éteindre le
fond en annonçant des mesures pour aider
les agriculteurs la majorité n'avait pas
l'air convaincu et TF1 a trouvé une
agricultrice du finisterère satisfaite
de ces mesures regardez êtes-vous
satisfaite des annonces du Premier
ministre on imagine que oui en toute
honnêteté je suis satisfaite des
annonces du Premier ministre d'ailleurs
il a très vite pris en considération les
la demande des agriculteurs la colère
des agriculteurs et je crois que depuis
que il est ministre il a pu répondre
très rapidement sur chaque situation et
c'est ce qu'il a fait aujourd'hui action
réaction problème solution et vraiment
il a annoncé des mesures très concrètes
pour les agriculteurs qui vont leur
faciliter la vie au quotidien bon elle
est elle est top mais son avis n'était
vraiment pas celui de la majorité
regardez on va discuter entre nous et
mais on va continuer la manifestation
non non on s'arrête pas là non non je
suis désolé là il y a pas il y a pas
assez ce qui est demandé au Premier
ministre c'est des mesures
franco-françaises sur ces mesures là
pour l'instant on n déjà pas toutes les
réponses je suis un peu pessimiste on
verra à l'avenir
qui va ressortir il manque du concret
plus de la moitié de revendications
qu'on avait n'ont pas été entendu mais
j'aimerais juste qu'on voit la vidéo de
de TF1 cité TF1 parce que Sandrine
leffur elle nous a dit qu'ils étaient
satisfaits les agriculteurs c'est pas
possible regardez êtes-vous satisfaite
des annonces du Premier ministre on
imagine que oui en toute honnêteté je
suis satisfaite des annonces du Premier
ministre d'ailleurs il a très vite pris
en considération les la demande des
agriculteurs la colère des agriculteurs
et je crois que depuis que il est
ministre il a pu répondre très
rapidement sur chaque sit alors bah oui
bah les députés renaissance du finisterè
Sandrine B sandrinef1 c'est pas possible
non mais les gars faites attention sans
rigoler non mais sans charier faites
attention c'est pas c'est pas c'est
facile le boulot oh là là là là nous on
a reproché d'avoir invité des gars qui
étaient pas de la bravem il y en avait
un de la bravem ils l'ont dit ici ils on
fait tout un tout un tout un tout un
truc et les gars bah oui mais c'est
c'est pas crédible bah oui a un problème
de crédibilité on j'ai rien contre elle
elle l'air très sympa en plus he
Sandrine mais bon le problème c'est
qu'elle est député renaissance du
Finistère elle va pas dire député
renaissance du Finistère non les
annonces du Premier ministre ne me vont
pas forcément ça colle pas ah oui un
problème c'est comme si moi je disais
que j'aimais pas les animaux sur C8 non
mais c'est vrai ah oui les gars il y a
un souci bon c'est que vous vous ont
plus vou les annonces du Premier
ministre ou pas du tout
c'est très léger quand même très très
très léger c'est vrai que quoi c'est
c'est qu'est-ce qu'est-ce que vous
attendez ça ça va pas existant il a il a
annoncé quelque chose quelques points
comme des points bloquants pour nous
c'est l'ofb il a annoncé le désarmement
de l'ofb la mise sous sous la
responsabilité des préfectures bon c'est
des premiers points mais après c'est le
reste c'est quasi inexistant il a parlé
du carburant des agriculteurs mais il y
a tellement la liste est tellement
longue que Ben va il va falloir aller
bien plus loin que ça ouais vous êtes
pas satisfait aujourd'hui du tout vous
non plus non non bonsoir à tout le monde
effectivement ça nous c'est un bel effet
d'annonce effectivement on voit qu'on a
une écoute maintenant on attend des
réponses concrètes on a fait une liste
de de doléan et on souhaite que en face
de toute cette liste et bien une réponse
concrète du gouvernement pour nos
revendications il y a un enjeu majeur il
y a environ la moitié des exploitations
agrico qui d'ici 10 ans vont être à
reprendre c'est environ 160000 180000
exploitation agricole si on donne pas
une nouvelle un nouvel élan à
l'agriculture française tous les jeunes
qui regardent ce soir ne seront pas
intéressés pour reprendre les
exploitations et on va encore augmenter
les importations de produits étrangers
en France alors vous êtes les
initiateurs d'imbarrage dans loise on
parler dans un instant vous allez nous
dire jusqu'à quand vous allez bloquer
quels sont les prochaines prochaines
actions que vous allez faire est-ce que
vous pouvez nous dire euh déjà les deux
j'adore discuter avec vous je vous le
dis et tous les agriculteurs avec qui je
parle je vous jure je trouve qu'à chaque
fois ce sont des mecs incroyables je
suis j'en ai croiser plein ce weekend et
ils sont d'une gentillesse ils sont
tellement je vous dis vous êtes
tellement ouvert au dialogue et ouvert à
la négociation et vous êtes tellement
dans un truc c'est ils sont pas c'est
pas agressif c'est c'est c'est
franchement c'est je vous jure je voyais
les gendarmes avec les policiers les
gendarmes avec les agriculteurs tout se
passe bien les gendarmes sont contents
d'être là j'ai vu les gendarmes onont
dit la police disait on est là juste
pour les les les protéger aussi parce
que voilà il faut pas qu' qu'il ait des
fous parce qu' se passe des trucs de fou
moi il y a un mec qui m'a raconté un
gendarme il a un mec qui Ava un barrage
il est arrivé avec un couteau comme ça
il a voulu crever les pneus de tous les
les trucs tout ça ça été un truc de fou
il s'est barré après ils ont dû le
poursuivre donc je vous dis il y a quand
même des mecs qui qui font des actions
mais ils sont tellement je vous dis
c'est c'est leur action on la comprend
tous parce qu'on je vous dis ils ont des
des normes et des on les étrangle voilà
les agriculteurs on en parle depuis des
années dans cette émission mais en plus
je vous dis il y a aucune agressivité
sur sur les sur les barrages ses Bones
enfant c'est vraiment ils veulent que ça
avance mais c'est dans la bonne humeur
et toujours dans le respect de l'autre
et même j'ai j'ai pas vu un agriculteur
avec qui j'ai discuté ce weekend qui
avait de la qui avait qui avait de la la
méchanceté ou qui avait de la haine ou
de la Harne envers le gouvernement
envers les ils sont tous on a envie de
discuter on a envie qu'on se penche vers
nous et on a envie un moment qu'on nous
aide c'est ça et moi je trouve ça
exceptionnel et je trouve que le
mouvement que vous mettez en place
depuis quelques jours c'est un mouvement
qui fait plaisir voilà je le dis parce
que je trouve que vous faites ça
vraiment dans les règles et et vous
faites ça vraiment on a envie on a tous
envie d'être derrière vous parce que je
vous dis voilà c'est il y a pas de
débordement enfin voilà il y a mais
c'est c'est en tout cas c'est pas de
votre fête à chaque fois c'estd que je
vois ils m'ont dit dès qu'il y a un mec
qui qui fait le malin ou qui qui est pas
dans le qui est pas dans les clous on le
sort c'est ça c'est ça tout à fait voà
exactement en tout cas merci d'être là r
Christophe est-ce que vous pouvez nous
dire à 20h 24 en direct voilà de vous
êtes initiateur des d'un marrage dans
l'Oise deux mesures vraiment les deux
mesures qui ferait que tout ça s'arrête
et que tout reprend et qu'on qu'on
repart alors Christophe la
surtransposition des normes alors alors
est-ce que pouvez nous expliquer pour no
téléspectateurs il y a des normes qui
qui descendent de Bruxelles de l'Europe
qui est quelque part nousous montre des
voies d'amélioration de nos pratiques
agricoles et on les respecte mais par
contre le côté français d'en rajouter
toujours une couche par rapport à mon
voisin allemand mon belge bah ça me gêne
parce que c'est la distorion de
concurrence pour ça on le dit à chaque
fois donc ça c'est la première mesure
justement va s'arrêter de petite seconde
sur celle-ci qu'est-ce qui fait que le
gouvernement aujourd'hui ils disent pas
on va se faire comme nos amis européens
puis qu' on prend souvent l'Europe en en
exemple he là il faut le prendre faut
prendre l'Europe en exemple les autres
pays européens en exemple et dire ben on
va faire exactement comme eux et on va
pas rajouter des normes sur déjà de la
norme alors qu'est-ce qui fait
qu'aujourd'hui il le disent ils disent
non parce que ça pour moi ça je
comprends pas ça ça normalement ça
devrait poser aucun problème